that's what it's that thing that was on
your arm is from Wakanda what condiment
what I am interested in is the thing
that could actually I'm not doing any of
this acting well so I started let's
start again
[Music]
excited happening up in here it's pretty
boring to me when I love you the pizza
but you're putting me off it's hard to
say that with the big sorry
[Music]
a judge Ross
your highness
oh yeah uh-oh
please give us a second
listen it's not my place to say man I
really don't think you should do this
what you guys have is gonna scare a lot
of people in that way we're gonna come
after you
yes but I will no longer rule after fear
not ours or anyone elses yeah I figured
you'd say that
well okay I'll do my best to keep mop
your back we're gonna hold you to that
everything I see in there or to Chawla
I'm Adam Sandler Nancy Calello it was
close it was close no way by practice
back table Diana Gabaldon my name is
king T'Challa son of King to Chaka
hey everybody it's Charlie so they
dropped the Black Panther blu-ray they
have all kinds of bonus features I love
that Angela Bassett is just like
completely unfazed by all the stuff that
they're filming at warrior Falls there's
an exciting [ __ ] going on here it´ll
attention right who plays Sheree is
trying to stay in character the whole
time like oh yeah you know exciting
exciting stuff happening so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there is a black panther blu-ray
giveaway that's going on - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video the deleted
scene is actually pretty interesting -
it gives you an idea for what Everett
Ross is gonna be doing now when you
don't see him on screen all the time
like he didn't appear during infinity
war but Martin Freeman did say that he
had more movies on his contract so he
would pop up again so I'm assuming that
means at least the Black Panther sequel
maybe Avengers 4 maybe Captain Marvel
because he was an Air Force pilot
Captain Marvel is an Air Force pilot so
there's just a number of logical ways
that he could come back but also when
he's talking to Black Panther here and
he's advising him not to tell the United
Nations that he's opening up Wakanda and
telling them about the resources that
they have in starting the exchange
programs when he says they're going to
come for you he's talking about
straight-up villains like Kraven the
hunter for instance who was a villain
that they tried to include in the first
Black Panther movie but thank Kevin
Feige the producers ryan coogler the
director decided to just hold off on him
so if you're wondering where Kraven the
hunter is going to pop up next it's
probably going to be in the Black
Panther sequel or in a future Black
Panther movie but Everett Ross is also
implying that the other people that will
come to take what Wakanda has are the
other governments of the United Nations
they're so like you have that funny
moment during the actual scene that made
it into the movie where you have the
version of Waldorf and Statler from the
Muppets that just sort of guffaw when
Black Panther says that they have a lot
to offer like what does a third world
country like Wakanda have to offer
developed nations like ours and he just
smiles then it
to the credits so you just have to
imagine that they're gonna continue that
threat in the next black panther film
right now they're mostly consumed with
fixing the universe after the snap sure
so just careful for spoilers for
infinity war if you haven't seen it yet
a lot of you asking now if Cherie is
going to become queen of Wakanda if
she's gonna become the new black panther
or if she's gonna become the new Iron
Man there's just a lot of questions
about the future of Wakanda before
Avengers 4 so as of right now my belief
is is that unless you see a body or
unless you saw someone turn to ash or
the directors specifically said oh this
person was turned to ash they're fine
so that means that Cherie is probably
fine during infinity war she was wearing
that black dress that looked very much
like her version of the Black Panther
costume in the comics so I think that
they just wanted to imply that she would
be in charge shortly even though she
didn't know it herself but just to put
it into perspective even though she's
supposed to be super smart one of the
smartest people on the planet she's
still a teenager in spider-man I would
say is around like 16 or 17 years old
right now she's supposed to be about the
same age as Peter Parker so you have to
imagine that she has all these
responsibilities when Avengers 4 picks
up but because that movie you know maybe
winds up being like two and a half hours
about the same length as infinity war
was you have to imagine that while
she'll be dealing with all these big
issues it probably won't be that long
before Black Panther comes back I think
a lot of people came out of Black
Panther really excited about that
character then they saw that he was only
in infinity war for like ten minutes and
then they killed him off and we're kind
of upset by that I think given some of
the critical reaction to the last couple
of movies they'll continue to tune
Avengers 4 to play to that like oh okay
we can focus a little bit more on these
characters because they're a little more
popular it was even a story recently
about Nate Moore who's one of the big
Black Panther producers who's been
shepherding that character ever since
civil war it was his idea originally to
use Black Panther during civil war when
they needed another character so when he
found out that the Russos planned to
kill Black Panther during infinity war
he actually went to them and tried to
change their mind so it gives you an
idea for how the executives even at the
most powerful levels within Marvel will
disagree about certain story beads or
what they're doing with certain
characters like that kind of happened
when Thor was coming from Thor Ragnarok
Chris Hemsworth in real life
has become powerful enough and there was
enough critical reaction to the
character in that movie that they were
able to go to the Russos and say hey you
know we knew you had some ideas for this
character but we really want you to
write to this version of Thor that he
became during Ragnarok instead of trying
to come up with your own ideas for what
Thor should be like but let me know in
the comments how do you want them to use
Wakanda surety in black panther during
avengers 4 because i've talked about it
a lot in other videos about the way they
view the afterlife in the ancestral
plane because of the big soul gem twists
there are a number of black pants or
concepts that they could borrow for
Avengers 4 like I said there's a black
panther blu-ray giveaway that's going on
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video Jesse F please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I'll
name a new winner when I post new Marvel
and also be doing an infinity war
blu-ray giveaway pretty soon too so just
keep your eyes peeled for that click
here to learn about the new villain
coming to the Spider Man sequel and
click here for all my Deadpool Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you